[Music]
I'm Nicolas and this is my wife Rebecca
and we're from winter garden which is
just outside of Orlando Florida growing
up I was never bad with money when I
went into the Marine Corps the natural
thing to do is back from a deployment is
to buy a brand new car with a car
payment because that was what people did
everybody has a car payment when I was
growing up my grandfather was kind of
the smart one with money and he would
always say when he turn 18 make sure you
get a credit card so that you can get
your credit score up and be able to get
a house and this man I was like okay I
used it I paid it off every month
probably for the first six months and
then I was like oh I have all this
credit I can use so that was kind of the
start of my being normal
Nick got back from Afghanistan and we
moved down here officially
and we shortly after bought this house
and we were just living the dream we had
this beautiful house we were newly
married we started buying a lot of
things bought new furniture we bought a
few motorcycles we of course needed new
cars at that point if we wanted to buy
something we bought it there was never
really a financial discussion having to
come across Dave Ramsey on the radio
when somebody was doing there definitely
scream and that first debt-free scream
pretty much got me hooked I wanted her
to have that same feeling as I did and
then I finally talked her Becca in to go
on a Financial Peace University and I
think that was the turning point she
talked me into going to financial peace
by saying to me we could pay off all of
our debt we could have no car payment
everything changed once we went through
that class
it took a good 3 to 6 months to finally
knock out a budget without disagreement
involved the every dollar budget at the
beginning of every month made us come to
the table together and talk about our
finances I think that right there helped
our relationship especially the
communication portion of being in a
marriage it forced us to communicate we
really hit the ground running we put all
the desks in a row it worked like he
said it made us feel good it made us
feel like we were rolling that snowball
then we got to a point where we needed
more money so Nick started selling
everything he had a garage full of toys
we had a garage sale we sold one of the
cars that we had car payments on and I
got a little 2 thousand dollar car to
commute back and forth to school but no
air conditioning or anything like that
selling them helped us knock out big
parts of our debt immediately and see
that progress and know that we were
getting somewhere and we we had a goal
in mind one of the main things that
motivated me and kept me going was
having Jackson it was so motivating to
know that I was going to leave a smart
financial legacy for my son in the end
we ended up paying off about a hundred
and thirty six thousand dollars in debt
in just about 30 months it wasn't easy
if there are a lot of sacrifices that we
had to make our communication has grown
and we've grown together in marriage as
a couple it was all worth it it was
definitely worth it to now live be able
to live our life like no one else
we since have saved up to buy our first
car in cash and I tell everybody about
it I see we got a new car we bought in
cash
growing up in living in our society it's
considered impossible almost to save up
money and go and buy something any type
of thing that we want we are now
budgeting and saving for it and just
being debt-free is just a weight off our
our lives I guess you could say so I
looked online for different debt-free
screams Becca and I wanted to go to
Nashville and do our debt-free scream
talking face-to-face with Dave it was so
fun just to go there and sign the debt
free wall and have a cookie at Martha's
place and be there with Rebecca and
Jackson had just experienced like none
other
[Music]
[Music]